bonjour bonjour et bienvenue sur
diagonale tv pour la deuxième partie de
ce championnat du monde
anand carcelle match revanche donc après
la première partie qui a vu donc un an
d'écart scène faire nul on va voir pour
la première fois dans ce championnat du
monde est bien qu'arsène jouer avec les
blancs et on va voir donc comment les
choses vont se présenter ce qui va être
intéressant évidemment pour ensuite
avoir un recul dans les parties
suivantes alors on y va tout de suite
dans cette partie deuxième de ce
championnat du monde 2014 avec le coup
de kars ya eu 4 donc là car sinon il
choisit d'ouvrir du pion du roi le 5 de
la part d'alain pourquoi pas évidemment
on est en attente c'est tout jouer jouer
des céciliennes aussi bien sûr il peut
il à il a choisi donc pourquoi pas
bomber de démarrer ce championnat du
monde par le coup eu cinq cas relief
trois cavaliers c6 donc jusqu ici là
pourquoi pas on s'oriente vers toutes
les possibilités sont encore ouvertes
avec le coup issifou c4 on pourrait
avoir pourquoi pas une italienne faut
rappeler que kasparov lui-même à jouer
ce coup avec succès d'ailleurs face à un
homme d'ailleurs je crois bien qu'il
avait bien une belle partie d'ailleurs
face à hollande avec le coup c'est 4 qui
est pas trés pas souvent joué 1 qui
reste un coup un peu à l'ancienne un peu
romantique un coup du xviiie ou du 19e
siècle mais qui a son venin foulée 5 la
fameuse partie espagnole qui remonte à
rui lopes oui lopes donc qui ont leur
remonte au 16e siècle la grande époque
de l'espagne ou alors d'autres
possibilités comme aussi le compte des 4
qu'ils ont et qui d'ailleurs est aussi
été jouée par par kaspar enfin avec des
écossaises ou des trucs comme ça donc
tout à fait jouable et l'a donc choisi
car scène de jouer au foot j'ai cinq
faux b5 pardon donc l'idée de fou b5
dans l'espagnol s'est d'abord un homme
sortir le fou très important on prépare
le rock
et puis deux pourquoi pas tout de suite
ou plus tard de prendre ces 6 le
défenseur depuis en scène pour pouvoir
ensuite gober ce pion avec le club des
f3
c'est classique mais en pratique c'est
très difficile de les gober le pion aux
scènes parce que après fou préemption
prend cavale et prend la dame vient en
d4 et en fait on récupère soit le câble
et sur le pion donc bon on pratique
c'est quasiment impossible alors qu'à
relief 6 alors ça c'est surprenant c'est
la fameuse défense de berlin qu'on
connaît maintenant
depuis que cramique lamy en championnat
du monde face à kasparov en l'an 2000 à
vendre jamais un championnat du monde
n'a vu la défense de berlin arrivé le
coût standard c'est plutôt de jouer le
coup à 6 au lieu de 4,6 qui a été le
coup fortement joué par
et bien karpov tout simplement face à
kasparov dans tous leurs malles des
matches qui les ont opposés septs
défense espagnol a été jouée une
quantité de foi innombrables et bien là
la défense de berlin alors allez
surprenante parce qu'elles mènent à des
finales technique
or l'analyse disons qu'on peut faire du
jeu de carsen et qui justement il est
supérieur dans les finales technique
donc autant on pouvait comprendre le
choix de cramique parce que kasparov
avait justement un jeu qui lui faisait
essayer de prendre un avantage décisif
et notamment la fin l'initiative dans
l'ouverture avec un jeu d'attaqué
foudroyant et souvent des attaques de
maths et chronique a démontré qu' il
pouvait il avait mis très mal à l'aise
dans justement des parties très sèche
très très technique et/ou final les
blancs on n'arrivait pas enfin kasparov
en tout cas le style de caspar n'arrive
pas à percer là on alla anin en quelque
sorte propose un quart scène de jousse
d'aller jouer sur son terrain
c'est à dire de l'affronter dans une
finale technique ou manifestement
car ce n est supérieur comme on l'a vu
d'ailleurs dans la première partie où
des jacquards scène avec les noirs
réussi à
tenir contre l'initiative d'anne en bon
on a peut-être joué un peu imprécis mais
et puis est rentré dans une finale
technique où il a presque pris
l'avantagé il a fallu qu'à nantes joue
très précis pour réaliser à la fin est
bon on va voir on va voir ce que ça
donne mais déjà ce choix moi me semble
d'un point de vue
général plus psychologique est générale
en termes de stratégie du match un peu
un peu curieux voilà un peu curieux des
trois parts
car celle bon pourquoi pas donc là c'est
presque une anti nanti berlin parce
qu'en fait il semblerait que
le berlioz ou plutôt des quatre des
choses comme des 4 ou des choses comme
ça la d31 jeu tranquille quoi en fait
voilà trois detroit il protège le pink a
tout simplement à vendre ok donc il
rentre pas c'est typique wallace et on
est vraiment mon style quoi donc la
hesse canada prévu son coup simple qui
allait la mener dans une finale
enfin dans une partie on va voir demain
parti un peu spécial quoi alors poussé
celle d'un homme pourquoi pas mais sûr
on développe le fou bon c5 effectivement
il semble bien placé on va faire le rock
est toujours si on peut développer le
fond ces cinq plutôt qu'un set bon il
est plus actif a priori insensé
s'indigne sur cette île et passifs
bon on va voir petit rock tranquillement
l'instant on dévoile rien des six alors
des six c'est déjà un coup responsable
puisque on empêche la retraite en
recettes
donc on peut pas revenir avec fawcett
bon s'auto cloud lecavalier puisque bon
maintenant le cavalier effectivement été
cloué un coin du feu mais on protège et
cinq bien sûr et on prépare la sortie du
fou si vite vous évite maintenant à lui
une belle diagonale devant devant lui
pour aller se poster par exemple
enchaîné 4 ou pourquoi pas 1,6 donc on y
va tout re le gic
alors ce coup évident sur protège le
public a donc plus tard pourquoi pas
après décès trois des quatre bombes et
on a déjà protégés de clients 4 c'est
bien et puis aussi on libère la case f1
qui est souvent utile parce que
lecavalier b1 et parfois même souvent il
vient enfin en fait il vient et fun et
après il va en g3 pour viser la classe f
5 ou ce genre de choses
ou parfois même en 3 il peut aussi aller
voilà donc on voit que c'est aussi voilà
il ya une double idée au couteau un mais
c'est toujours bien évidemment quand on
rock c'est toujours pour amener les
toits verts le centre donc si on peut
annuler à tour le sentier toujours mieux
petit rock fou prend cavaliers ça y est
maintenant que le roi à roque est bon
mais les blancs se disent mais peut-être
que le foulard maintenant de toute façon
il peut être pris par les noirs avec le
fameux a6b saint-cloud échasses et puis
on pourrait jouer cavalier à 5 et de
toute façon il sera échangé donc autant
le prendre en doublant les pions noirs
voilà donc pourquoi pas pion prince et
six et les noirs ou des pions doublé en
échange de quoi ils ont tout de suite la
paire de foule on va voir que la paire
de fou c'est pas si nette
h3 très important très certainement
maintenant de la part
ici de carcelle il empêche simplement le
fou de venir sur la casse g4 est aussi
est aussi dans ce type de position il
est parfois intéressant de jeu cave
alliage 2 suivi de calais g4 on aime
bien avant le plus rage 3 pour protéger
la position du cavalier voilà donc une
double idée h36 est pas qu un coup le
coup classique de de la petite fenêtre
du roi on a une petite fenêtre qui
empêche aussi le mode du couloir sachez
tous les débutants connaissent ça c'est
important de se ménager tôt ou tard une
petite fenêtre ça empêche surtout le
développement du fourrage et 4k une des
cases naturel du fou et ça permet cette
manoeuvre ultérieure pourquoi pas les
considérations encore général on
dézingue ouverture tout est logique
regardez comme les deux joueurs ne
perdent pas de temps à jouer plusieurs
fois la même pièce ici toutes les pièces
se développe tours 8
les noirs font un peu pareil pourquoi
pas tours 8
l'idée peut être aussi d'amener un
cavalier en fuite un cavalier 17
cavaliers fuite pourquoi parce que
parfois on a envie de jouer le coup fcf
s'est protégé par le foot c'est 8
c'est un coup d' attaques possibles
quand y'a pas d' attaques contre le roi
noir et le cavalier fuite est un très
bon défenseur du roi aussi donc ça peut
être une idée aussi
pareil de libérer la case et fuite en
même temps que d'avoir une action vers
le centre aux six cavaliers des deux
vous regardez vous avez vu comme ce
qu'avait dit sort sur la case d2 et non
pas sur la case d3 ici parce que bombay
en c3 où c'est qui qu'est-ce qu'ils
contrôlent
ils contrôlent bombay inde et 5 c b 5 vu
que le piot les pions sont doublés c'est
pas très utile et donc il a peut-être
plus envie de se diriger vers les fins
et pourquoi pas soit 11,3 soit j'ai
trois soirs et pourquoi pas mais match
2-1 pour viser mc alger 4 aussi donc
c'est plutôt son collègue qui ont envie
de faire ça un développement rampant
classique et là regardez tout de suite
calais 17 ce qu'on disait tu ce que je
disais tout à l'heure
quelle est cette et pourquoi pas oui
préparer cette poussée f5 plus tard
cavalli ces quatre autres idées de
calais d2 c'est de venir maintenant sur
la casse c4 alors c'est d'autant plus
intéressant que les noirs n'ont pas leur
position à leur disposition par dont le
coût b5 qui effectivement est un coup
qui aurait pu chasser le cavalier en lui
demandant gentiment de rentrer à la
maison
ce coût n'est plus possible à cause du
doublage des pions donc il est pas si
mal en c4 ce cavalier puisque bon ben il
fait pression sur le conseil notamment
regarder si les noirs essaie de le
chasser par des cinq puis on prend
d'abord puis on prend et tout simplement
prendre le pion de 5 et voilà on est
devant un problème puisqu'on a perdu
mais monsieur on a tout simplement fait
pression sur le sec ce qui empêche une
libération possible par des cinq aussi
voilà il est bien placé ce cavalier pas
mal bien placé ses pièces la foulée 6
alors faut b6 coup un peu maintenant la
demande pourquoi jouez vous b6 on rejoue
le même fou il n'a peut-être pas trop
d'idées non plus la non dans cette
position je sais pas ce qu'il a envie de
jouer c'est 5 pour bloquer la casse des
4 et dans ce cas là le fouet
et vraiment enfermés derrière ses pions
c'est pas forcément une chose qu'on a
envie de faire
pourquoi je vous il faut b6 moi je sais
pas trop là je serai que c'est un peu
délicat commente escoulen c'est un coup
de retrait il a toujours pas sûr qu'ils
sont fous ces 8 août à es17 et en
attente peut-être qu'il a envie aussi de
jouer qui avait laissé cinq on enlève le
fou pour positionner soi-même un
cavalier en scène mais c'est pas pareil
que ce qu'on a vu pour les blancs
puisque les blancs pourrait chasser ce
cavalier par b4 donc c'est un peu
délicat a expliqué bon c'est un coup de
grands maîtres de champion du monde donc
on laisse faire alors évidemment coup
nature et à quatre bons mètres on joue
un v6 à quatre jeux menaces à 5 et le
fousseret obligées de rogner ans et 5
avec la possibilité après de gagner du
temps voire de le chasser avec ses 3
suivi soit deux des quatre pour attaquer
au sein de soi même de b4 et le foot
doit partir en retraite donc sur à
quatre on n'a pas trop envie alors on
peut jouer soit à 6 soit à 5 puisque à 6
ou sites intéressants pourquoi pas si on
veut pas mettre un pion à 5 le problème
un pion à 5
on va le voir tout de suite puisque
c'est ce que vous un angle ce pion et
quand même isolé regardez la personne
pour le protéger à l'aube ont ainsi si
les plus loin à attaquer pour les blancs
mais ici regardez il peut aussi être
attaqués à terme par le fou des deux on
pourrait imaginer que la tour joué à eux
deux la dame a eu 1 puis ça fait un deux
trois pièces comptera 5
donc c'est une cible aussi 1 donc bon je
sais pas alors on notait que à cette
menace pas de jouer fois cette année on
peut pas enlever le fou parce que
lecavalier
quoique si c'est possible remarquez on
pourrait aussi jouer fois cette même si
on se demande ce que devient le pion à 5
parce qu'en cas de cavaliers prend il ya
fou prend un échec
on reprend après on prendra vie mais
enfin c'est vraiment du bricolage et
c'est pas c'est pas forcément très bon
pour les noirs puisqu'il ya un pion
passé après le pion à quatre du côté
blanc ce qui devient un gros problème
donc la non car scène se pose pas de
questions il prend tout de suite
quelle épreuve les 6
qu'allaient prendre les six il est
difficile pour les noirs d'envisager de
prendre du cavalier parce que le pion à
5 qui est toujours isolée
le calibre 6 de plus devant à une
impossibilité de bouger il n'est pas
forcément à sa bonne place d'un compère
du temps aussi
et puis le plus ancien que vous remettre
devenir une vraie cible alors la food &
deux fous ces trois dames d2 et puis on
est obligés de faire quelque chose pour
défendre ce pion et donc d'avoir des
pièces très resserrée du côté noir donc
c'est pas bon et le coup naturel c'est
bien entendu ses preuves et 6 passes
quand des clous dans des doubles pardon
on dédouble les pions les pions ne sont
plus doublé donc c'est bien d4
évidemment d 4d 4 on n'a pas peur de
pions prendre d 4d noir puisque on
reprendrait la dame est tout de suite
déjà on attaque le fou le pion des six
avec pression surtout que derrière on
aura envie de jouer aussi fou et f4
comme moi c'est essayer de se
débrouiller pour jouer au f4 ce même si
c'est pas simple mais déjà regardé un
coup comme dame et 6 pour protéger des
six il y aura le fou angers 5 qui
attaquent la dame tout de suite on perd
du temps bon bref c'est après on peut
jouer les fourrages 4 et le fond j'ai
trois et ils deviennent très dur de
défendre ce pion des six
donc on va pas prendre avec les noirs et
avec les blancs bombés on prend de
l'espace et les blancs bombe à une
position une partie facile à là
maintenant après ces manoeuvres jouer de
parts et d'autres
donc dames c'est cette ici de la part
d'un land bon il position de saddam
ils veulent à placer sur une bonne case
c'est vrai que là on avait un pion
notamment ses 6 qui était pas protégés
on sait pas encore on va mettre ce fou
s'est vite on aurait pu essayer de le
mettre en baisse est en baisse 7 il est
derrière le pion si on bouge le pion ses
pions b6 qui devient arriérés
donc on va voir ce qu'on va voir on a
déjà un problème de structure du côté
noir c'est à dire que la bon c'est
encore ça va mais ses pions d'avancé
donc c'est un peu plus faible que si
j'étais en première ronde sur la rangée
de débats alors regardez un très joli
coup de car c'est maintenant au tour à
trois très simple l'idée est la suivante
a aussi ses où vas tu fous finalement
parce qu'en g5 il apte à créer un en
trois ils bouchent l'action de la tour
notamment cass de prix en cas de prise
ici bombay selon serait peut-être obligé
de prendre du fou je ne sais pas on fait
en tout cas c'est possible d'envisager
fou et 3 mai il taperait un peu sur le
plan b 6 mai on va mettre ce plan b si
c'est très bien défendu on fait 3 bon
pied après qu'est ce qu'on fait
t'auras 3 c'est très souple et on va le
voir après les coudes à deux suivants et
en plus c'est classique dans les
positions de type espagnol là ça
ressemble à une position espagnole cette
position on est revenu dans une position
espagnole avec l'ordre des coûts de
carsen on sait très intéressant la façon
dont tu as joué car cette ouverture et
cette tour en a 3 peuvent coulisser soit
en b3 pourquoi pas pour attaquer mais si
surtout en c3 pour attaquer si ce qui
est quand même un petit pion faible dans
la position noir qui est pas facile à
attaquer mais déjà à mettre ces trois
ans montre que bon on trouve un moyen de
lui de lui mettre un peu de pression
pourquoi pas mais surtout on peut aller
en f3 on chez trois ans visant leur
endroit donc c'est tout en passant par
a3 empêche enfin résout le problème du
fou noir finalement ou mieux développer
le fond noir ben finalement sur sa case
de départ il est bien il peut aller
encore n'importe où il a un petit oeil
sur la case h6 donc pourquoi pas une
attaque vers le roi la tour à 3 peut
maintenant coulisses et une fois que
cavalier blanc aura joué on va voir on
va voir que ces mêmes c'est ce qui va se
passer
cavalier fuite de la part d'un an on
avait parlé c'est une case naturel pour
le rct aussi une classe naturelle pour
le cas les blancs mais on a vu que ans
et catherine était bien aussi bon mais
là cavalier fuite pour les noirs c'est
bien ça libère le fou c'est 8 qui lui
aussi j'ai envie de dire à sa meilleure
case sur sa case de départ
parce que bon c'est cette île fait rien
on voit pas trop comment il va s'activer
parce que si on joue c'est 5 on a un
pion b6 arriérés
même si le foot bien sûr à du jeu bon
c'est jouable
c'est pourquoi pas mais peut-être on a
simplement n'a envie de le laisser là
pour garder toutes les options
bon pour l'instant à 6,6 peut se
développer aussi une étape dans le vide
diagonale ici maintenant qui est
complètement l'inusité pas du tout joué
de la part des blancs donc il serait un
peu hors jeu puis laisserait la case f5
on va voir qui est importante puisque
après des princes 5 des points 5,2
carsen kivu très simple magnifique
caillage 4 cariat h4 une autre idée de
des positions du type espagnol
vous verrez il ya des parties de fisher
notamment et beaucoup de parties de
fichiers notamment dans son match de 92
face à ce parce qu'ils nous fichent hier
à jouer des coups comme tour à 3 dans
l'espagnol bon là c'est un espagnol avec
moins de pièces puisqu'on a déjà échangé
des choses pas mal mais on a la même
idée d' attaques contre le roi avec des
tours à 3 et coulissage voilà donc à
noter que cette tour peut aussi venir en
d3 avec une pression sur la colonne des
ou angers 3 contre le roi ou en c3 face
option c6 donc elle est magnifique cette
tour en fait c'est vraiment une d'or à
regarder son homologue set elle n'a pas
la possibilité voyez à cause des pions
en b 6 et 6 peut pas coulisser quoi en
fait
donc les blancs ont plus d espace bon
c'est pas davantage décisif bien sûr
mais bon ils ont quand même plus d
espace et de la dynamique contre le roi
noir
donc c'est un peu chaud tour des huit de
la part des noirs donc la halde joue bas
il veut pas développer son fou comme on
l'a dit parce que revenons juste avant
en levant un peu de vert parce qu'il y
en a beaucoup
ce fou il peut pas développer sur casier
quand on a déjà vu un cause 2 h 3 puis
maintenant plus il va y avoir trouvé 3
il ya la dame il ya tout bon c'est mort
depuis longtemps en 6 pourquoi pas mais
ils enlèvent une case aux cavaliers et
en plus si bush l'action de la tour bon
pourquoi pas ceci dit mme étape dans le
vide donc finalement est ce qu'il n'est
pas bien placé déjà là et bien placé la
bombe donc qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est le
problème parce que si les labels et
tours sont pas liées et notamment n'a
pas la colonne ne peut pas aller sur la
colonne des avec l'autre la torah vite
on aimerait bien le faire mais on met où
le fou ces problèmes alors il aurait pu
quand même joué fou aux six tours à des
8 et peut-être remettre le fou ans et 8
après je sais pas des choses comme ça
c'est possible c'est envisageable
bon pour l'instant ils se débrouillent
pas donc il fait tour des huit y joue
l'autre tour voilà il joue la tour sur
la il se dit mais finalement il n'est
pas utile à 1,5 parce que en fait on va
voir que l'idée d'alain de 7 jours et 6
alors si on joue et si sûr protégé puis
on s'est dit pourquoi pas et en plus
pour protéger la septième avec la dame
là on attaque en par tour des huit ans
fait un tape tout en libérant la tour
ici bon on active la pièce mais bon
est-ce que ce coût est moins utile on
sait pas damages 5,2 carsen c'est
logique c'est logique
la tour est prête à venir en g3 mais
pourquoi pas vous rappeler qu'elle peut
aussi faire pression sur ces 6 pourquoi
pas un f3 aussi pourquoi pas puisque mon
ex est même s'il ya la dame qui protège
bien on commence avec la tôle la dame du
côté roy alors attention et du côté noir
des coups comme g6 c'est délicat parce
que j'ai six bien sûr ça tape la dame il
faudra la jouer souvent quand on
réfléchit pas trop hein ce genre de
contacts qu'on a tendance à vouloir
fermer non parce que la dame bien h6 le
fouet de 15 mois on affaiblit les cases
noires donc une pénétration maintenant
du fou vient le viager 5 et f6 d'autant
que ces lots donc possible que l'on peut
jouer touristes -trois je vous rappelle
donc protéger la case et 6
et puis déjà on a des menaces de maths
donc voyez ça peut aller très vite donc
il est interdit de jouer v6 1 c'est
vraiment pas non et c'est pas l'idée
d'un land c'est bien sûr de jouer m6
regardez ici les pions sont sur noir et
le fou et sur carte blanche quelque
chose qu'on a vu aussi en première
partie dans la première partie du match
toujours cette complémentarité voyez
quand vous êtes en complément de jouer
les pions sur la couleur opposée du fou
de quasi blanche donc les plans sont
quasiment donc les pièces sont
complémentaires
ceci dit c'est ce qu'on préfère faire
quand on est en attaque quand ton en
défense parfois celle inverse on lui met
les pions sur castres les couleurs du
founan si on veut défendre bon ceci dit
lassé particuliers notamment par le fait
qu'on a des fous de couleurs opposées
les fous de couleurs opposées
il faut bien faire quelque chose pour
contrôler les cases voyez on contrôler
toutes les cases ici avec les noirs les
cases du fou grâce aux pions voilà les
pions ici nous permettent de contrôler
les cases du fou c'est un fait donc
c'est complémentaire du fou est alors
très important à le coup et si je
surprotège 5 qui était quand même
attaqué par la msa chèques
il ya une petite attaque ici même si la
défense et la dame aussi protège la
septième rangée
voilà donc c'est un coup de défense
classique cavaliers 5,2 carsen ça y est
le cavalier bien sûr s'il est là les
années là non seulement c'était pour
libérer la tour mais c'est aussi pour
rentrer en jeu alors il ya kasparov qui
nous disait que si j'ai un cavalier on
peut considérer qu'un cavalier sur la
case f5 houle inverse un cavalier noir
sur la case f4 est bien positionné et
ans qui l'attaquent g7
ils attaquent h6 il contrôle des cases
important dans le noir il disait ça vous
inquiète on pourrait considérer que ici
que carsen aurait presque eu besoin de
plus pourquoi pas bon il faut bien sûr
c'est pas le cas
ceci dit c'est dangereux c'est dangereux
puis alors on veut pas on veut pas trop
donné le fou contre ce cavalier parce
que que deviendrait dans ce cas là
maintenant les cases blanches ail et ça
devient faible
bon ceci dit c'est vrai que les blancs
n'ont plus que la dame pour attaquer les
cases blanches à plus de fouet mais on a
on a on aurait affaibli les cases
blanches c'est des cases qui devait une
rue quand même faible et donc ça peut
quand même être dangereux
donc ici maintenant c'est leur fout
aussi ce très bien alors l'idée de faux
six bambins sur s'est développé le fou
ça c'est fait est ce qu'il aurait pu
envisager autre chose ici
non bien sûr ils ont pu aussi jouer
d'ahmed 7 km 7 était jouable pour
questionner la dame mais sans doute la
dame serait venu en deux ou peut-être en
h4
quoiqu'en h4 qui ont eu qu'un v6 qui
attaquent la dame aussi bon mais c'était
possible aussi d'envisager de mettre
cette île aurait pu aussi bien sûr
proposer les changements il choisit il
faut aussi ce pourquoi pas l'intérêt
bien sûr aussi c'est lié les tours voilà
maintenant la question que je me pose
est ce que finalement un coup comme tour
à cette n'aurait pas été plus tarder on
va faire une petite variante ici plus
solides tour à 7
regardez je prépare pourquoi pas d'avis
est toujours jouable au cas tension
après tout j'ai 3 ici il y aura un
clouage et donc à cavalier échec avec
fourchette donc attention faut pas le
faire quand la tour hier mais pour
l'instant la tour était pas là le plus
faire avant la même recette mais tour à
cette je protège la scène jeux
surprotège la septième et en même temps
c'est tour pourra venir plus tard sur la
colonne d ici en 17
et si la dame quitte cette diagonale
envisager un échange ici et plus on
n'échange plus la pression diminue quand
on est en défense il vaut mieux changer
des pièces dont moi j'aurais aimé
j'aurais préféré le coutour à 7
c'est un coup de défense là aussi
latéral voyez comme la date ou attaquant
latéral pourquoi pas de défendre en
latéral ça se fait beaucoup notamment
dans l'est dans les attaques indienne
bon pourquoi pas touché 3 il a joué faut
aussi ce tour g3 voilà alors le problème
maintenant de toucher trois sets ça
menace déjà des choses tout ranger cette
gamme la dame était un pion et la dame
le cavalier protège on peut pas jouer
dans mes recettes qui attaqueraient la
dame non plus à cause de cavaliers h 6
échecs et on gagne la dame net qui
serait une catastrophe évidemment donc
que faire la tour g3 alors on en trouve
un bon coup bien sûr il vous qu'avez
léger 6 ceci dit moi j'aime pas trop ce
coup parce que lecavalier on a envie de
laisser ensuite commencer un cavalier
défend bien d'un coup plus naturelle
entre guillemets c'était de jouer le
coup tours 17
et c'était logique puisqu'on avait sorti
le fou donc après avoir sorti fou tour
17 on n'aurait pas boucher le fou s'est
vite on prépare l'arrivée de la 2ème
tour au centre et ça me paraissait plus
plus naturel quoi voilà bon plus naturel
et puis on prépare la le développement
de la dernière pièce au lieu de quoi il
rejoue une pièce carrelée g6 bon
pourquoi pas effectivement le cas
valises s'interpose entre eux la tour
est le roi mais si on n'est pas à l'aise
parce que ce cavalier la même si ça va
pas être immédiat mais regardez il va y
avoir et on peut faire h4 et plus tard
h5 il suffira de sortir la dame h 5 e
caraïbes où j'ai touché 7 qui menacent
donc c'est une défense qui marche mais
qui sur le moyen terme est quand même un
peu bancal quoi voilà donc c'est un peu
un peu risque ou ce quoi alors qu'un
coup comme tour dès cet été sans doute
plus souple on laisse le carrier en
défense ont sûrement sur des surprotège
g7 avec des pièces les pièces lourdes
on pouvait même envisagé regarder pour
revenir cette mission autour des 7 tours
et tours 7 ah non il ya le cavalier mais
peut-être après un échange autour et on
surprotège tout bon pourquoi pas mais je
reprenne sans doute retour des 8es
essayé ensuite des sciences des changes
et une paire de tours sur la case d1 en
s'aidant de la dame s'était peut-être
possible bon câble et g6 pourquoi pas
mais voyez c'est une défense un peu
tendu coin parce que on peut pas
empêcher h 4 h 5 et il va venir assez
vite et c'est ce que fait à carson tout
de suite
d'ailleurs je pense que ce coup il a
joué assez vite à d'ailleurs ici h4
bombay attention on va sortir la dame
par exemple en a eu deux on reste sur
cette diagonale avec la dame de son bras
on n'a pas le choix et on joue à chaque
menace pour projet 7 donc la bombe et
anand choisi là encore bizarrement de
liquider son fou fou preuve cinq mois ça
me paraît douteuse encore une fois parce
que ce fou il contrôle les cases
blanches
même si ce cavalier pénible encore une
fois je pense qu'aucun tour 17 mois me
semblait plus encore une fois plus
souple bon évidemment difficile à donner
des arguments concrets
technique mais ça me paraît plus ou
parce que j'ai envie de sortir cette
aura 8 qui pour l'instant fait rien à 8
ans on défend à 5 qui déjà défendue par
b6 donc à 5 et très déjà très bien
défendu c'est pas la peine de laisser
cette tour là c'est tour ne joue pas bon
donc bon je sais pas moi j'aurais fait
quand même j'aurais préféré doublé mais
tour et laisser que font que font les
blancs quoi parce que je vois pas
comment les blancs auraient pu menacer
grand chose avec une tour en 17
on contrôle très bien les choses bon
faut prendre 5 est douteux moi je le dis
que c'est douteux parce que la regarder
en plus on perd mais touche suite pro f
5 et ça y est le cavalier jécistes
obligé de sortir bon alors c'est ce que
fait bien sûr pas non et il le met en f4
bon est ce qu'il aurait pu revenir en
fuite oui mais bon déjà c'est chaud quoi
parce que fois ci c'est possible attaque
g7 et on est quand même ton temps obligé
de jouer autour des 7 donc pourquoi ne
pas la voir jouer tout de suite et avoir
laissé se fout en russie ce bon alors
cavaliers f4 foot pro f4 de la part des
blancs direct carsen s'embarrasse pas
évidemment pourquoi ben parce que bon le
café f4 on peut pas le tolérer il est
très fort aussi
autant le cavaliere s'inquiétait fort
dans le fou le cavaliere 4 aussi était
très fort le problème vient c'est qu'il
n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de symétrie
dans la position c'était parce qu'après
eux prend f4 bien sûr les deux pions
lasson quelle que soit leur forme de
symétrie mais c'est toujours là est plus
actif que celle là c'est là aux origines
de résident de la différence quand même
et en plus en faisant faux prêtre
capillon près de 4 les blancs ont libéré
la colonie pour la tour et notamment
regarder on a une magnifique asie 6 ans
et 6 de pénétration protégé par un pion
ce qui est idéal et on voit tout de
suite l'intérêt du coup tours c3 puisque
on en a parlé tout à l'heure cette
course et tout pouvait qu'au lycée
partout on attaque le pion c6 est
maintenant en plus la deuxième tour peut
venir chatouiller la 6e manger des noix
où se trouvent les pions et si les pions
bougies s'affaiblissent c'est délicat et
le pion le roi noir est un peu plus
faible que le roi blanc à cause de ce
pion ce coup et si cela qui affaiblit un
peu
les diagonales thomas un échec peut
traîner sur casse blanche après tour
aussi cela d'armes peuvent venir à eux
deux on peut envisager des plus tard
détour cette dame six échecs des dalles
c4 avec des visas vis c'est évidemment
la nand à jouer une défense un peu un
peu curieux alors il a été peut-être
surpris par la façon de carsen de jouer
contre la berlinoise avec ce cette
ouverture anti berlinoise qu'à trouver
car c'est là une façon de de transposer
la finale que proposent les noirs cette
facette heures technique qui força des
finales technique dans une finale
technique mais l avantage des blancs c5
tout de suite de la part d'un homme qui
anticipent tour c6 il aurait peut-être
pu atteindre tous et si c'est jouer un
coup utile ce qui pouvait pas à leur nom
ils pouvaient pas attention il y avait
un piège aussi on peut pas jouer autour
des 7 maintenant parce qu'il y aurait
tout rishek le roi peut pas sortir a
expliqué la dame tout reprend tour et
d'emprunts tour matt on peut on peut
voir cette variante voilà partir hop
variante tour 17 tours 8
échec y'a pas d'autres coûts que tour
par tour et après dang tran ici roy et
échec et mat
voyez donc attention
donc une menace ici donc on peut
évidemment pas joué tour d'essai dont il
fallait trouver un coup on peut pas non
plus jouer tour tour à 7 comme on
pouvait le faire tout à l'heure c'est la
même idée
donc on est déjà un peu embêté en fait
on est déjà un peu embêté si on joue à
six avec les noirs qui est notre coup
possible bon bien sûr c'est possible
mais ça affaiblit encore les cases
blanches autour du roi
donc bon c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
surtout qu on n'empêche pas la suite
bon bref donc qui jouent ces cinq là
peut-être pas d'autres coups en fait
c'est déjà le problème est déjà embêté
voiliers et tout ça devient du de ce
fameux coup là de scouts alors qu'à
l'aller g6 et peut-être envie d'échanger
des pièces mais peut-être il a fait trop
tôt au lieu d'activer ces tours dans une
première il pouvait quand même activer
ses tours c'est curieux qu'un an de se
fasse déborder comme ça de façon de
techniques systématiquement la tour
aussi ce très joli coup normal naturel
de car c'est ni la tour sur la casse
forte un protégé par action elf scène
dans le camp noir et ben ont fait
pression sur le pion des six donc déjà
les noirs peuvent pas faire ce qu'ils
veulent un de leurs dames plus bouger
d'un match 7
après l'échangé des dames et la perte du
plan b 6 maintenant les blancs peuvent
aussi envisager de rajouter de la
pression pourquoi pas en b3 sur b 6
la dame aussi maintenant que la tour est
passé on peut venir derrière la tour ce
qui est toujours mieux vaut mieux avoir
la dame derrière ces tours que devant
voilà alors les noirs sont obligés de
jouer tout rabais 8 un coup super passif
c'est lourd mais on surprotège b si ce
qui est des gènes cibles
c'est bien ça libère la dame noire on va
pouvoir pousser la dame mais c'est
passif
bien sûr regardé à la différence que les
deux tours blanches sont extrêmement
active alors peut-être un peu moins là
pour ces trois tout tout oui ces trois
tout de suite pour l'instant elle est un
peu passive bien sûr parce qu'elle est
bloqué mais bon elle va pouvoir
s'activer assez vite notamment elle peut
venir en c4 pour ensuite venir 1,4 et en
plus on va faire pression sur le pion f4
alors qu'on n'a pas l'équivalent du côté
non je vous rappelle que c'est pas
possible de venir chatouiller pur
excellent puisqu'on à matt le roi noir
est plus faible que le roi blanc
pour ces quatre voiliers tranquille
larsen ne fait tout de suite tour ces
quatre normales sa dernière pièce non
actives c'est la tour qui a fait son
travail
on a forcé les noirs à s'affaiblir
regardez comme ces structures est faible
le pion b6 est arriérée cerci bougeait
bien il va être pris et on a deux pions
noirs qui vont être qui risque d'être
isolé il est sous la pression et surtout
belle et blanc vont maintenant doubler
tripler sur le colonel avait des menaces
contre le roi noir pénétration sur la 7e
ou pénétration sur la huitième déjà les
noirs sont mal dame 17 alors qu'ils
n'ont pas fait de grosses fautes c'est
une accumulation de petites avantages de
la part de carsen qui bizarrement mais
qu'il est plus jeune que 1 an 2 semble
plus patient 3 h 2 alors watch de
l'hydro h 2b
c'est évidemment de diviser des échecs
ici notamment regarder si d'âme des uns
maintenant pour la part des de la part
des nord proposé un échange de dames
ça a l'air fort parce que bon les blancs
sont quasiment obligée de d'échangés et
la tour après pour être sur la deuxième
et ça pourra contre-attaqué l'attaquent
des noirs mais ça marche pas parce que
tour d'amd 1 tour 8 échecs
le roi ne peut pas bouger il faut
prendre la tour et la dame n'est plus
protégé d'emprunt dames c'est pas mal
cette fois c'est la perte de la nappe
donc un jour à h2o on empêche les noirs
de faire les changes qu'ils avaient en
calcul et de faire damer échec tout
simplement donc à un autre qu'ils
trouvent des coûts le problème regardez
c'est maintenant le pion aux 4 est perdu
il est en prise non défendu donc ce coup
donne 17 ne marche pas on sache deux
tours il fut quand même ils reviennent
penser cette année joue pas un coup
parce qu'après dames c'est cette aurait
pu s'il y en avait je vous donne set
pour revenir protéger pions f4 bon
d'abord je peux toujours revenir adam f
3 et
envisager de le prendre dans une
possibilité mais surtout je n'empêche
pas vraiment un doublage de tours et
j'ai pas peur d'eux ff3 avec échec puis
simplement je joue j'ai 3 et le pion f3
et perdu avec un puits entre un noir un
roi blanc très bien protégés et en robe
noire toujours toujours un peu en l'air
une colonne ne seront aux mains des
blancs c'est déjà très dur t'aurais
fuite tour ce4 de la part de carsen ça y
est la batterie on peut pas opposer une
tour sur la huitième et tout ça encore
une fois je pense que ça vient du péché
originel de qu'on a vu au début d'avoir
défendu le rock par le cavalier g6 qui
est quand même au lieu d'avoir tout joué
tour 17 et d'avoir activé la tour
précédemment les blancs et sans doute
pas pu augmenter la pression de la de la
même façon tours 6e 4 tours bessette
voilà enfin obligé de jeu tour bessette
mais là encore regarder on avait dit dès
le début que tour à sète était une
défense latérale est il obligé de le
faire maintenant
on ne peut pas jouer tout recette
puisque dans ce cas là la dame prendrait
la première on aurait pris deux tours
pour la dame et les noirs très
certainement peuvent arriver à annuler
sa avoir même pourquoi pas tenter de la
gagner parce que deux tours sont souvent
supérieurs ndam donc c'est hors de
question de faire ça pour qu'arsène on
défend la 7e et on pouvait le faire il
ya longtemps déjà et on a perdu du temps
par la manoeuvre en essayant de changer
des pièces
finalement je vois une fille dans
l'intérieur c'est très étonnant que
comme la technique de carsen comme ça
arrive à a surpassé celle d'un homme qui
quand même bon avait pas pas le dernier
venu en technique c'est quand même très
très grand joueur technique aussi et
bizarrement ils ont l'impression qu'ils
précipitent comme ça il se précipite
trop et il ne consolide pas assez sa
position je pense qu'une karpov aurait
pas aurait pas jouer de la même façon
cette cette finale dames deux
de la part de kars el tri plage c'est
chaud c'est chou alors maintenant on
menace effectivement tours 7
triplement vadis précipite pas car c'est
là essayer de prendre le plus riche 4
notamment la prise de plein air 4
ben on en aurait enlevé du contrôle sur
la colonie se précipitent pas il sait
qu'il est perdu ce pion et dorment pas
les blancs oui les noirs ont pas
l'équivalent voilà que font les noix
imaginons que les noirs jouent un coup
comme dan des 5 c'était envisageable
pour attaquer le racing mais simplement
de tourcoing f4 et on garde tout
contrôle de la colo ne contrôle sur le
pion sur le pion f5
pas de problème pour on peut centraliser
on peut par exemple jouer des coups
comme ici comme dame c4 propos proposer
les changes des dames avec sinon
évidemment un échec à la découverte
possible avec la tour aussi si on
n'échange pas voir en dames 4 bien sûr
on va pas jouer tour 4 puis ce qu'on a
on veut pas faire le pitre 5
maintenant on a besoin de plus même si
c'est un pion de doubler mais c'est un
pion f5 et quand même avancé et qui fait
pression sur laurent blanc qui contrôle
la case aussi c'est un pion fort ce pion
donc dans me2 alors attention il ya
toujours des possibilités de faire nu
dans les finales de pièces lourdes bon
mais là non né va essayer de jouer dur
maintenant de créer du contre jeu donc
il joue ici b5
bon c'est logique 1b 5 ils essaient de
crédit contre jeu en essayant d'échangés
la bla ils menacent plus on prend et
puis la prison b2 bien sûr et d'essai
d'activer ces pièces d'activer notamment
sur la colonne b bon pourquoi pas car
c'est normal et se précipite pas il joue
b3 je sais pas s'il aurait pas pu aussi
envisagé à prendre mais 5 à prendre les
5 est jouable dans ce cas là
probablement d'en prendre 5 et après un
coup comme
d'en prendre et en pro b 5 simplement
effectivement tout reprendre des 5 et je
fais pression sur b3 on peut quand même
jouer effectivement le b3 et b3 empêche
quand même les noirs de bouger leurs
pions et on a toujours une position
agréable à jouer deux côtés blanc mais
peut-être maintenant tour b4
effectivement je protège f4 c'est
peut-être l'idée d'annoncer ce qu'ils
voulaient jouer quelque chose dans ce
style la bombe est saine mais simplement
b3 et après puis on prend b4 qui on
promet 4 c'est la même idée tombé 4 on a
tombé 4 l'idée c'est l'idée d'un an
c'est à dire que j'ai activé mes pièces
puisque tombé 4 je protège le pion f4
par transparence ici c'est au est quand
même plus active ici qu'elle ne l'était
là bas mais en échange bombay j'ai des
pions isoler les doubles et blanc aussi
c'est vrai et j'en pêche pas les blancs
de contrôler la colonie donc là le coup
logique après cet ours est bien sur
l'idée s'est passée la 7ème avec
avantage les blancs sont quand même
beaucoup mieux
là un homme joue d'amd 6 attention petit
menace quand même f3 échec au roi et la
dame d'oé perdu en impression cannes en
fait s'ennuie dans cette position là et
qu'il a il arrive pas jouer à trouver
les coups qu'on a vu tout à l'heure et
que
en fait il essayait de précipiter ils
essaient de précipiter les choses pour
essayer d'arriver à la nulle facile
rapide alors que personne début de sa
partie là qu'on en fait voilà donc on
est on est on vraiment de joueurs
imposition de style ici entre joueurs de
plus tôt de d'ouverture et de milieux de
jeu qui est un an d un joueur de finale
qui est qui et car ce n est un joueur
extrêmement technique en finale et c'est
extrêmement précis d'un f3 qui accumule
des petits avantages à lord ahmed 3
c'est un joli coup ça bloque le pion f4
tout simplement et sadi à anand à toi
qu'est ce tu joues et oui à toi qu'est
ce que tu fous parce qu' une des menaces
ici des blancs ça peut être de jouer
tout simplement tour à cette menace tout
alors là si on double les tours sur la
7e c'est fini terminé fermer rideaux
donc à nant élimine une tour ça c'est
normal
et après d'hommes prend 1,4 car c est
toujours mieux colonne eux bon il ya un
an et demi dans une tour on peut plus
doubler les tours son 7e mais on est
mieux attention il ya quand même des
menaces possibles on peut on peut
simplement même proposer l'échangé d'âme
parce que la dame six échecs dames
prendra monde prend du pion et ça y est
le pion de plus devient un pur normal il
est c'est plus un pion doublé ce pion
reste doublé donc roi rage 3 roger 4 va
poser un problème on risque de perdre ce
pion avec un avantage d'un but urnes est
un pion proche de dames les pions à cinq
essais 5 sont faibles c'est choquant
c'est même plutôt chaud donc là on en
joue
le curieux
f 3 échecs bon pourquoi pas le problème
dénoncé que c'est pas une brume un bon
c'est mieux ça fait échange si on
pouvait changer puristes roi contre-pied
g2 ce sont d'excellentes nouvelles pour
les noirs ont s'élimine le pion faible
et on affaiblit la structure blanche
mais évidemment joué trois très
simplement déploré ce tronc est perdue
donc
là l'idée d'un en impression cannes on a
complètement perdu pied dans cette
partie comme s'ils voulaient pas la
jouer essayer de forcer l'annuler que en
fait car cindy mais non je la joue c'est
il ya encore beaucoup de choses à dire
qu'arsène voit des choses en finale que
canon ne doit pas apparemment hélas
alors lane à nanjing a faim il ya une
menace dans cette position je vous
laisse y réfléchir deux secondes si
c'était aux blancs de jouer c'est comme
ça qu'on va les menaces qu'est-ce qu'on
joue et voilà il faut parer cette menace
un coup logique ici pour les noirs c'est
de simplement souvent quand on est
menacée la solution c'est de
contre-attaquer dame en d2 bien sûr si
j'amène la dame sur la casse des deux
j'attaque le pion deux et ça pose un
problème aux blancs que faire si on
prend le pion f3 ce qui est jouable mais
on perd le pion c2 et là il ya un pion
passé noir et c'est plus la même c'est
plus la même partie ça continue bon donc
sur dam des deux je ne sais pas ce
qu'avait prévu car scène mais c'était
quand même jouable
les deux
ici bon simplement on pouvait par
exemple prendre quand même le pion f3 et
après dame prend ces deux simplement
protégé avec le roi et la menace qu'on
va voir tout de suite existe et c'était
jouable
ça reste encore jouable même si les
blancs toujours davantage pourquoi parce
que bella tour simplement ici beaucoup
plus actif que son adversaire le roi
noir est beaucoup plus un danger que le
roi blanc bras là on regardait beaucoup
plus de pions autour de lui que le roi
noir ici ça fait quatre là il y en a que
3 et en plus on a joué et 6 cas
faiblissant d'où la grande
responsabilité qui a de jouer les pions
de vence on voit donc après d'emprunt
tour ici après les changes
anand aurait pu jouer le ku'damm des
deux quand même bon même si c'est
difficile
au lieu de quoi donc
échec j'ai trois au lieu de dames d2 et
donc ici pardon et gains à nantes joue
le coup perdant tout simplement h5
alors bien sûr hymne y ménage une porte
de sortie pour son roi ils contrôlent la
case g4 dans l'impression qu'il a
complètement perdu pied alors peut-être
que simplement lieu s'éviter une finale
perdant il sait déjà que ces perdants
mais peut-être qu'il n'a pas compris
pourquoi comment il est arrivé là quoi
c'est ça qui est ça qui est un peu
disons un peu qui fait un peu peur pour
à nantes pour la suite du match c'est
que si on va se retrouver comme un match
comme la premier lot comme le premier
match où finalement un quart scène va
gagner des parties en finale de façon
tranquille parce qu'alain n'arrive pas à
y jouer
ana n'arrive pas à jouer les finales
quoi car ce n est trop fort en finale il
voit des choses que l'on ne voit pas
regardez simplement dame 17
c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure des
cornées sur la 7e c'est fini et c'est
fini on peut pas empêcher pourtant g7
suivie du matin on peut
faut donner un homme tu apprends tour
d'un probable anand abandonne dans cette
position voyez donc le dernier coup
d'annoncés vendre une gaffe et encore
d'un des deux possibles mais peut-être
il a même estimé qu' il était déjà
perdue c'est possible voilà donc voilà
bon je pense que je pense que le plan
des landes lui convenait pas je pense
qu'il s'est précipité si on revient je
dirais que pour moi dans cette partie je
pense que la clé du match s'est jouée
ici encore là encore ça va ici voilà
qu'à valider 6 kb/j 6 me semble une
façon de défendre l' attaque pas pas top
top quoi je pense qu'un coup comme tour
17 était plus approprié tour 17 pour que
l'otan puisse venir en jeu voilà je
pense que c'était c'était le mieux est
alors que calais g6 on voit bien bien
sûr ça change des pièces on dit souvent
quand on est en défense qu'il vaut mieux
éviter d'avoir trop de pièces en face de
soi donc essayer d'éliminer des pièces
certes mais pas au prix d'avoir une
finale inférieur voilà et on a vu que
finalement ce plan d'un an qui finit par
avoir le cavaliere f4 une prise est donc
donné la colonie ou blanc ben on voit
bien qu'à la fin
et c'est très très dur à défendre et
même il finit par gaffes et parce que la
pression est forte aussi et que même
sans ça de toute façon la position
blanche était supérieur donc les chances
de gain de car ce n était est et était
visible donc ça part mal pour un homme
puisque après donc deux parties il est
mené 1 0
il est minime des d'un point donc un
ennemi 0,5 à son compte la nul donc ça
part mal mais bon il reste encore pas
mal de parties s'il ya douze parties
faux billets on va voir comment il
réagit quand même une bonne position
dans la première il faut peut-être qu'à
nantes se résolvent a effectivement
accepter de jouer des finales supérieur
comme il aurait pu dans la première on a
vu s'il avait accepté échange des dames
lors une finale un peu plus supérieur un
peu supérieures et qui laissait pas de
gagner la partie
comme il a pu avoir l'habitude de le
faire peut-être jusqu'à présent plus
dans le milieu de jeu et en termes de
positionnement et de et d'essayer plus
de de jouer ces finales que carsen
veut jouer ces finales où la différence
est faible mais existent il peut aussi
qu'un nom de jouer dans ces finales un
peu supérieurs mais délaissée par son
style peut-être il n'a pas envie de le
faire et c'est ça qui lui pose problème
voilà donc rendez-vous à la troisième
partie pour suivre la suite de ce match
où carsen a déjà pris davantage mais qui
une suite de match qui s'annonce tout à
fait intéressante pour voir si un an de
contrairement au premier match donc
arrive à revenir dans la partie
merci d'avoir suivi cette partie et donc
à la prochaine
au revoir